بتبقى فادت وكاله الانباء الحكوميه ان
سبعه جنود من الجيش الصومالي قتلوا في
هجوم لحركه الشباب على قاعده عسكريه في
جلعت باقليم الجنوب وسط البلد اضافه
الوكاله ان القوات ان القوات الجيش صدت
الهجوم على القاعده وقتلت 100 مسلح من
الحركه من جانبه قال المتحدث باسم الحركه
عبد العزيز ابو مصعب ان مقاتلهم قتلوا مئه
و 159 من افراد القوات الحكوميه بينهم
ضباط وانهم هاجموا القاعده على ثلاثه
جبهات
والحق اضرار كبيرا بالعتاد العسكري
معنى من مقديشوراس الجزيره جامع النور
جامع حل اتضح التفاصيل اكثر والى اين وصلت
الامور
التفاصيل المتوفره هي تاتي حصريا من
الطرفين المتنازعين في هذه
المدينه هذا البيان الاخيره الذي اصدرته
الحكومه الصوماليه وهو اول تعليق لها منذ
وقوع هذا الهجوم صباح هذا اليوم تحدث عن
مقتل من مقاتل حركه شباب الذين هاجموا هذه
القاعده ايضا تحدث عن احراق وتدمير سبعه
سيارات قالوا انهم ان هذه السيارات كانت
الحركه قد استورت عليها في حروب سابقه
ايضا في هذا البيان من لوزاره الاعلام
الصوماليه همم فيه شكر
لجهات همم ما سمته شركاء الدوليين الذين
ساعدوا الحكومه الصوماليه في الحاقه
الهزيمه لهذه القوات وهذا يؤكد ما كنا
نشير اليه منذ حدود وقوع هذا الانفجار من
منذ الصباح من ان- اا هناك مسيرات امريكيه
شاركت وتعقبت المهاجمين من حركه الشباب
بعد ان هاجموا على هذه القاعده التي كان
يتواجد فيها وحدات ميناء منذ قوات النخبه
الصوماليه همم وفقا المعلومات التي حصلنا
عليها كانت في هذه القاعده وحدات من قوات
النخبه الذنب وايضا وحدات من نحب النخبه
جورجر وهاتين الوحدتين من القوات الاولى
هي تدربها الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وتقدم لها التجهيزات العسكريه والدعم
اللوجستي وهذا ما يثبت همم مشاركه
المسيارات الامريكيه لملاحقه الحركه
الشباب هذه المدينه استولت عليها او
استردتها القوات الاحرار القوات الصوماليه
الاثنين الماضي واقامه فيها هذه القاعده
العسكريه ضمن حمله تقوم بها القوات
الصوماليه في منطقه في مناطق عليهم الوسطى
الصوماليه لكن الملفت في هذه العمليات ان
حركه الشباب كل ما همم
حاولت ان القوات ماليه الدخول الى هذه
المدن الكبرى كانت تتحاشى المواجهات
المباشره وتنسحب بكامل قواتها واعتادها من
تلك المدن ما يسهل لها في اطلاق
عفوا في شنه هجمات على تلك المدينه حدث
ذلك اكثر همم من مدينه واكثر من محور
المواجهات التي تدور بينها وبين القوات
الصومال الصوماليه كان اخرها في منطقه
حوادلي التي قتل فيها ايضا القائد قائد من
الوحده الثالثه في ميناء ايضا من الفرقه
السابع والعشرين من القوات الصوماليه همم
باختصار المعلومات المتوفره تاتي حصريا من
الطرفين المتنازعين في هذه المنطقه
والاعداد التي يقولها كله طرف تبدو كبيره
لكن ما هو مؤكد هو حصول هاديه هذا الهجوم
في هذه القاعده العسكريه الذي بدا مصادر
محليه
بتفجيرات واستمرت وحدث ايضا وقع هناك
مواجهات ما بين الطرفين استمرت لفتره ايه
طويله بعد ذلك حدث ال ال هذه التعقب الى
المسيرات الامن التي يعتقد انها امريكيه
للمقاتلين
نعم شكرا شكرا جزيلا لك من مقديش راس
الجزيره جميعا